well you have to know what your bottom
line is what do you have an alternative
because if you do not have another good
alternative you have less power there is
a power differential in all negotiation
of course the hostage negotiator has a
SWAT team behind them however I've never
seen a SWAT team actually resolved the
negotiation in and of itself it is the
negotiator person on person group on
group who is able to persuade that mind
shift change and it's built around trust
so you need to know what your other
alternatives are in order to not be
taken hostage the moment you say I have
to have this you lose power and what you
have to do is always remember there is
choice there is choice so Nelson Mandela
for example who spends 27 years in
prison comes out speaking reconciliation
and forgiveness here's a man who
understood that he was never a hostage
he never gave over his mind he was able
to focus on the fact that for 27 years
he was there for a training it was a
preparation for what to help bring South
Africa out of apartheid and when he came
out he did not show the hostage
mentality he actually became a great
leader so he he had basically no
alternatives while he was there except
to work with his mind understand and see
an opportunity can you imagine what it
was for 27 years to direct this
flashlight on opportunity so yes you
have to know what your options are
there's always choice I think the
biggest mistake leaders make is when
they forget they have choice and that
choice includes saying no walking away
some of the best negotiators in the
world will walk away because they see
that there is a reason that they cannot
go beyond the boundary now if you're a
hostage negotiator you can't just pack
up and say I walk away you have to keep
engaged in that dialogue and
order to maintain the bond and find a
solution but remember in a hostage
negotiation you have power because
people want something you only have to
find out what that other person wants
one of the biggest mistakes and
negotiation people don't take time to
understand what others really what can I
do
risk avoidance and the most dangerous
situation is someone who is altered by
drugs altered by ideology in in such a
way that you cannot get a mindset change
they refused a bond if you look at
Caliban you look at Virginia Tech here
was a couple examples of young boys who
simply could not create a bond and out
of this bond in this isolation the rage
came out and and and there there was
nothing to do at that point they they
just acted out this murderous rage where
hostage negotiations do fail in that
five percent it's because you cannot get
the bond with the person if you can get
that the probability is so high that you
will get a success however no guarantees
there was a number of years ago a
teacher in New Jersey who was taken
hostage by a high school student over a
grade dispute she had a tape recorder
she managed to tape a major part of that
dialogue she did everything correct she
built a bond she engaged in a dialogue
he was even giving her a hug the tape
ran out and in the end he killed her but
as best we could termined from that tape
she had done everything correct and we
have to recognize no human being has the
power to override the free will of
another human being
there's always choice however if you
understand how the brain works
the nature of the human it is around
social bonding it is around belonging
even if it appears that is not there and
if you understand grief and loss you
then begin to understand resistance to
change so that if the loss is so deep
you cannot get the bond then
do you may have limitations which i
think is another thing to really
understand around change and uncertainty
and leading in times of change
uncertainty is that it is the loss or
the fear of the loss that drives the
majority of behavior in every act of
violence in every hostage taking in
every conflict situation of significance
there is either a loss a change of
frustration of some kind of grief and
people who cannot go through the grief
over big things little things they
cannot then rebonding that's what
leaders have to do they have to help
people go through whatever pain
frustration or grief is there and come
back and I use that grief in weird grief
intentionally in the book there's a lot
in this to understand what motivates
people it's not benefits benefits don't
motivate most people it is the fear of
change it is the anticipated loss that
drives people into into negative